خلي عم يقعدها في هذه الندوه لكنها اصبحت
عنوان لها الصحفيه رشاء الحرازي التي قتلت
بعمليه ارهابيه في عدم قبل عام لا تزال
قضيه مقتل ها رهينه الادراج وفي ذكر
اغتيالها يناشد زملائها تحقيقا عداله
بحققات لها
ارتباطنا عرفت معنى الاسره وعظمه الاسره
وحب الاسره اليوم مرتبط
ما يحس في نفسه المجرمون
ومنخططه لهذا الجريمه البشعه الطلاقه
ويسعون لحصد المزيد من الارواح طالب وزاره
حقوق الانسان بالحكومه الشرعيه باعداد ملف
جنائي وحقوقي همم وتسلمهم منظمات الدوليه
لحالتها هذه الجريمه الى محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه باعتبارها جريمه حرب استهدفت حياه
صحفيه مدنيه همم غير مرتبطه باطراف النزاع
والاعتداءات الحوثيه على صحفيين اليمن
مستمره وتزداد معها اعداد الضحايا
واستخدمت الميلشات واساليب مختلفه ضدهم من
قنص وقتل مباشر وهجمات الارهابيه لمواجهه
الصحفيين هناك جرائم قسيمه ارتكبتها
ميليشيات الحوثيين ضد الصحفيين في اليمن
منها ما وثقتها تغارير صحفيه خلال عام
2021 قرابه 55 عمليه ارهابيه همم من ضمنها
زملاء همم
الزميل محمود العتمي والزميله همم غشاء
الحرازي اليمن بات ثالثه اختاري دول
العالم لعمل الصحفيين ومؤخرا لم تتوانى
الميليشات عن اغلاق عشرات المؤسسات
الاعلاميه ومصادره ممتلكتها ليصل الامر
الى اصدار احكام اعدام بحق اربعه صحفيين
السعيد العربيه تعز